So what is a script? A script is a knowledge representation for capturing
causally coherent set of events. Casually means that one event sets off another.
So when David goes to the coffee house, as soon as he approaches the counter,
the barista comes to him and says, what do you want? One event has set off
the next one. Coherent means the links between these events make sense in
the context of the world around us. So in David's script again,
ordering coffee doesn't cause the barista to slap in the face.
Because that would not be causally coherent in the context of the world.
These events are referent to events in the world. Some events, like deciding or
concluding, might be in the actor's mind, but for
the most part these events are observable events.